back in the early days of breath of the
wild in 2017 everything was simpler
something like parrying your own bomb
was a big deal back then
but nowadays that simply isn't enough
breath of the wild combat has morphed
into a complex monster of melding
techniques that requires an insane
amount of knowledge and frame perfect
timing so let's take a look at two
combat clips one from the first records
of advanced combat captured in 2017 and
the other captured this month in 2022
and see just the jump and complexity
breath of the wild players have gone
through through the years if you enjoy
this type of in-depth content let us
know with a like
with me today though i have another
combat expert to help explain some of
these intense mechanics hello my name is
hylian shibayino i've been doing
advanced combat for two years now and i
have over a thousand hours experience in
lino combat i will help explain some of
the techniques we'll see today perfect
because we're diving in the deep end of
advanced combat here and we'll need to
break down some things way back in 2017
i was the only person doing this type of
combat so this was still a very new
concept for most people so let's take a
look at one of the first advanced combat
clips ever made
[Applause]
[Music]
oh yeah i can tell this really is a no
clip so five years ago you used some
basic but very essential techniques like
jump canceling spin attacks and bomb
parries these techniques are not
actually normal operations for current
combat players and it's something we're
using every day in both combat and even
speedruns to quickly move on from the
attack with minimal delay
bomb parries were also a new concept
back then of pairing your own bomb's
explosion it jumped in difficulty today
because we used deruk's protection
instead to perform a perfect parry
against the explosions instead a much
more difficult parry but we'll get into
that later i also switch cancelled the
parry into a spin attack just like jump
cancelling its main purpose is to reduce
the end lag of attacks so i can get out
of the bomb parry animation as soon as
possible this was about as crazy as it
got back in the day this is okay but
combat has grown a lot since then so
let's look at something i would do today
in 2022
okay let's take a look
[Music]
yep that's a lot more complicated
especially when you know exactly how
hard this stuff is under the hood a
whole bunch of stuff happened back to
back in a short time so let's break it
down in order one at a time just as a
heads up though these explanations might
start to get a little heavy yeah this
might confuse some players so bear with
us so from the very beginning we see
here what's called a tldr a thunder
landing the rook rush not to be confused
with too long didn't read can you
explain how this works
sure so normally when using ubus's furry
in breath of the wild you have to charge
attack and release it and most players
just let the charge attack happen but
like we explained before we jump cancel
it to stop the annoying charge attack
and do whatever we want and still summon
mubasa at the same time so i chose to do
a backflip this is called an obasa
cancel and is the thunder part of the
tldr you can also do this by switching
your weapons to cancel a charging attack
like you did many years ago after
performing the robust cancel i did an
ldr or landing direct rush using the
lino's explosion to sprint towards the
center of the damage and successfully
hit the lino okay so this is when it
starts to get a little nutty to explain
this to a casual audience ldr by itself
is a very intricate technique because it
proves something that's very weird in
breath of the wild you can flurry rush
an attack that's not flurry rushable
think about it have you ever sidestepped
or backflipped a lioness explosion and
flurry rush it no you normally can't
it's actually impossible but using a
perfectly timed daruk's parry combined
with a back flip just as your feet land
on the ground triggers to mark the
center of the explosion itself as an
enemy target you're actually targeting
the lionel sword in this case not the
lionel itself the rook perfect parries
are also harder than normal shield
parries it's triggered by tapping or
releasing zl within two frames of an
attack hitting link this works for
almost anything that has link such as
enemy attacks
falling
bombs
bomb arrows
and linus explosions so for this first
part against the linus first explosion i
have to time my charge attack release
perform the obasa cancel time perfect
parry and even my back flip timing to
parry low to the ground to perform the
tldr
it's very complex but that's just part
one what's going on after the flurry
rush well there's nothing that's
actually advanced about this part but
after many hours playing it's just very
fluid quick menu movement to get set up
quickly
step by step i switch to master sword
jump to drop a bomb switch to stasis
through a mid-jump states the lineup
switched back to bombs and was ready to
go in around two seconds
after doing this so many times for so
long this kind of menu selecting becomes
second nature pretty much after i've set
up i begin the next part dsbr or the
rook show block reset the main goal of
dsbr is to get into bullet time whenever
you want the base technique to do here
is the sbr or shell block reset shell
block reset is a useful technique
because when you're blocking attack
where you're in the air link will get
knocked upwards a little bit and let you
jump afterwards so if you jump and shot
block reset you can jump again where i
back flipped here and got high enough to
trigger bullet time but this is a way
harder version because this is a dsbr
the rook's protection interferes with
shield block resets and will always
parry for you instead of letting you
block the attack so you have to jump
release the rook's protection block the
attack then jump again the next part
though is the toughest part yeah most
people won't even understand what is
happening right here this is pretty
difficult to do but can you explain why
it is this section is a quadrupole
deluxe perfect parry it's mostly for
show but does decent damage in bullet
time first i firebomb arrow point blank
and the rook's perfect parry the
explosion
then i drop the romp bomb and perfect
parry the explosion again then i drop
the square bomb in using the explosion
of the previous remote bomb
immediately explodes the second bomb
which i again perfect parried then the
last parry is slightly different but it
is also another perfect parry against
the bomb arrow explosion you can hear
the parry sound effect for every parry
that i do
four perfect parries in a row midair on
top of everything you did before and the
fourth period is different what happened
here before performing the fourth parry
i input r then immediately press y and
zr at the same time to initiate tcr also
known as thunderclap brush this is a
technique to force a flurry rush
whenever you want but this one is
special because normally a tcr like this
will move towards the liner you stay in
place and not move because it's unmarked
but if you fire bomb arrow perfect
period press r or b to exit bullet time
and land extremely fast you will move
and chase down your own bomb explosion
like an enemy which is called bomb arrow
absolute thunderclap brush or bomb arrow
atr techniques like this are extremely
complex and the names get very long so
some players like to also call this
firestorm rush
people really haven't seen how much
combat players have torn apart the
flurry rush system it's normally a very
simple system of dodge and attack and
chase the attacker but there are many
techniques out there that force flurry
rushes to happen out of thin air and
multiple techniques to mark projectiles
and custom targets so you can pick and
choose where you would like to flurry
rush it's advanced so much over the
years yep including the last technique
here after the previous combo i jump
cancel backwards drop another bomb
perfect period in flurry rush with a
spare again this is a basic perfect
direct rush the game thinks that the
bomb is an enemy attack and triggers a
flurry rush again so i do even more
damage to finish the combo
i'd say about 98 of the players out
there don't understand how these
mechanics work but that's just how
difficult these are to understand
personally though i feel like the old
grandpa of breath of the wild there are
many talented players out there that
took the mantle after discovering this
type of combat and you know what it's
cool to see how much it has evolved
since it was first created over the past
five years players constantly push
themselves to master these complex
techniques and what i showed was only a
small slice of what is possible which
shows how much breath of the wild has
evolved over their years as another
combat veteran once said people say
they've already mastered breath of the
wild but breath of the wild is a game
that you never master both the game and
the players will never stop growing
[Music]
if you enjoyed this video let us know in
the comments below we still make breath
of the wild content to this day so stick
around for everything else gaming though
keep it here on gamespot
[Music]
you